good morning john what why am i here
what
not a dance no dancing oh god no just
fyi i set your chair a little though
that joke never gets old to me did you i
did i did i have no idea oh no you're in
the same place at the same time because
it's our mother's birthday and she loves
that we're spending time
just as brothers and our spouses
favorite thing when we
sneak away we're gonna make a video and
play some spider-man video games hank i
know that you've asked the people of
twitter for some questions for me
did they deliver john yes have you read
any fanfic of your own books oh yeah
there's a lot of isaac related fault in
our stars fan fiction which is fun
there's even some people who wrote
versions of the fan fiction that daisy
writes in turtles all the way down yeah
i saw that by the way hank have i told
you that turtles all the way down is
actually going to be a movie like not
[ __ ] not for fun but for real i think
you're about to go have a conversation
with someone about it the star of
turtles all the way down isabella merced
whose face is currently covering hank's
face
you're going to do something video it's
your video you've got it you still got
to do that what happens when the sun
dies well i don't know what happens when
the sun dies but i i do believe that the
people who love us will miss us my
favorite keanu reeves life yeah that's
what happens after you die and that's
what happens when the sun dies no it's
not how do you keep learning things
after school stops i mean
crash course yeah use crash course this
was definitely a way that's one way but
in general don't you think it's about
pursuing inquiry and understanding how
to it's about being curious and knowing
how to chase the curiosity knowing how
to change that question that learning of
how to ask the question around the
question is kind of best done by reading
non-fiction i always sort of have a
block and i'm like i don't want to read
a big old book about that and then i do
and i'm like i have so many questions no
it was actually so interesting that's my
relationship with
science books books of medical history
history books i just get so
thrilled by it to me learning is about
getting in touch with that part of you
and then being having the time and the
space
and the the skill set to pursue that
curiosity what's your favorite like
thinking podcast where you like learn
stuff you didn't know before the
anthropocene reviewed oh my god you
literally knew everything in that
podcast it's the only podcast where you
knew everything when i started i love 99
invisible i feel like i learned so much
from it i learned so much from radio lab
from invisibilia there's a wonderful
podcast through line that i learned a
lot from little st james wants to know
do you have any elden ring strength
build pvp strategies i don't know what
any of those words mean why do i get
shocked by metal all the time in vegas
why does that happen there's no air in
the water there's no
water in the air there is no air in the
water it's a huge problem only fish have
solved it
is that why when the air is drier you
get shocked more is that why you get
shocked in winter because the air is dry
yeah yeah yeah yeah you remember when i
started a youtube channel called all the
questions yes and the goal was to answer
and answer every question yeah yeah you
never think small i was like we can just
record them 50 at a time you've got to
give an explanation because you got to
get watch time you do it like the
pronunciation guide where you like have
the video start and then like 15 30
seconds in you're like
horrors dusty's there's an app called
how jay say oh i know how jay says my
favorite thing is that he said
everything he didn't like just because
people know how to pronounce it doesn't
mean he hasn't said it right so he's
just up in here
good old jay i was dancing
there's not a lot of words to start with
but
also in the uk booty
what is that word hank it's a sandwich
that contains nothing but bread and
french fries so a chip buddy is a
particular kind of buddy and any kind of
disgusting buttered sandwich is a buddy
we actually have
french fries upstairs
we do we're gonna we're gonna go get a
chippy buddy john i'll see you on
tuesday and right now